and just like that Suicide Squad killed
the Justice League gets delayed yet
again Warner Brothers games scored a hit
with Hogwarts Legacy and the studio was
set to launch another game Suicide Squad
killed the Justice League in May but it
appears those plans have changed
Bloomberg reports that the game is now
delayed Beyond its previously announced
May 26th release date a new date was not
published in the report and Warner
Brothers itself has not confirmed the
delay reporter Jason schreier said the
delay is quote mainly for Polish after
the state of play many online were
unhappy to learn of the game's live
service approach but trius said the game
began as the games as service title and
will launch under that business model
and set up the game was originally
slated for release in 2022 before
getting pushed to 2023. this reads to me
that a delay even if the response to the
game's recent showcase was
overwhelmingly positive was always in
the cards for Suicide Squad however no
amount of Polish will improve the
elements of the game that caused the
negative response which are core to the
title's entire experience to address and
change those well it'd need to be a
whole different game and Rocksteady has
already spent eight years making this
one in a couple short years time it'll
be the 10th anniversary of the
developers last game Arkham Knight which
itself was released 10 years after the
original Resident Evil 4. now we are
weeks away from a remake of that game
but you don't have to wait that long to
get your hands on it at that same recent
stage of play presentation that Suicide
Squad was a part of Resident Evil 4
remake showed off a new trailer along
with an announcement that there would be
a special demo of the game available
soon as it turns out soon is now with
the demo becoming available after
today's Capcom Spotlight showcase which
also included looks at EXO Primal and
new content for Monster Hunter rise the
shadow drop of the demo which was meant
to be a surprise during the Showcase was
actually spoiled earlier in the day when
Twitter user Daniel S Kennedy spotted a
twitch ad for the free demo that was
seemingly published early with text that
read demo available now if you don't
need a demo to sell you on Resident Evil
4 remake there's a chance that you've
already pre-ordered the game's
collector's edition which includes a
statue of The Game's protagonist Leon
and is exclusive to GameStop GameStop
however has announced that all in-store
pre-orders for the collector's edition
are canceled Twitter deals Guru Warrior
64 was one of the first to announce the
news online some people also claiming
that their online pre-orders have been
canceled as well though the extent of
that has not been established this is
not the first time that GameStop has
struggled with a pre-order crisis last
September Kotaku reported that the
retailers database and inventory system
suffered a number of major issues that
caused locations to have incorrect
information about what games would be
available when which triggered a lot of
headaches for GameStop's staff the
outlet has reported that an internal
memo to employees at the company
confirms this most recent debacle is
also a side effect of that database
problem last fall and that anyone who
had their order canceled is eligible to
ten dollars off the standard edition if
you were one to pre-order this
collector's edition either in store or
online it would be best to check on its
status but please whatever you do be
kind to any GameStop employees you speak
to about this this is not those
individuals faults and I promise you
they're just as frustrated by the
situation as you are what do you think
about a possible delay for Suicide Squad
are you going to be playing the Resident
Evil 4 remake demo let us know in the
comments and we'll see you here for more
Gamespot news
[Music]
online